welcome back to Las Vegas now now if you
are thinking about selling your home but
are not happy with the current market
perhaps leasing your home is an option
right Harvey blankfeld with Las Vegas
real estate now the sponsors of this
segment are you're here with the answers
sir welcome back hey Rocky glad to be
back of course now what's going on in
the current market give us the rundown
so okay we've transitioned from a strong
seller's market a crazy strong seller's
market to a more neutral market and it's
actually heading to be towards buyers a
little bit and so if you're a seller out
there and you're saying gee I'm not
happy with the price I'm getting right
now you might want to consider leasing
the home app but there's things you got
to ask yourself first right and what are
those things there's the things first of
all can you afford to not take the
proceeds from a sale of a home to move
into another home uh the other thing is
is are you prepared to deal with the
idea that a tenant's going to be taking
care of the property instead of you
because tenants most tenants are very
very good but they're not quite as good
nightmare could be problematic and then
and then we always recommend of course
because we are a property manager that
you incorporate the the idea of having a
property manager to help you with that
prop with that property and that lease
right now why is a property manager
helpful there's a couple of reasons one
they completely insulate you from the
tenant it's hard for an owner of a home
to say no to a tenant if they ask can I
have this or can I have that if you say
no now that you're adversarial but when
you have a property manager we become
the bad guys more or less right and you
can do dirty work for us and you want to
make sure that also that as a prop the
property manager is taking care of the
property in the right way and they're
only using licensed professional people
to do repairs and things of that nature
because you want a property management
because there's also laws that dictate
the way landlords and tenants interact
with one another and you want to make
sure you're obeying us because they can
be expensive if you don't yeah a
property manager is helpful and it's
smart it's smart absolutely yeah for
sure now what's the difference between
owning a home and just owning an
investment property okay so when you own
a home and you need a repair you can do
it at your own Leisure and you can have
Uncle Bob do it right it doesn't matter
but when you own an investment property
you need to do things timely and you
need to do it with licensed
professionals and the reason you want to
do with a licensed professional is is
that if something goes wrong or that
repair isn't done properly and someone
gets hurt or result of it it's your
fault if it wasn't a profession but if
it was a licensed professional it's
their fault and you don't want to be
your fault okay okay and lastly here
does your insurance change if you're
leasing it does it's dramatic change in
insurance so when you change your home
from owner occupied to uh an investment
property you want to contact your
insurance Say Hey I want a landlord
policy now not an owner occupant it
changes from being covering a lot of
personal property to covering liability
issues more so okay and really quick
before we go tomorrow you guys are going
live for Las Vegas real estate now yeah
thanks Rocky we don't do live very often
but tomorrow we have Bronson Mack on
from the Southern Nevada Water Authority
and he's going to talk about our water
situation here and everybody can call in
and ask him a question so I know
everyone's concerned about our water
situation yeah we love Bronson here he's
always got really great tips well thank
you so much Harvey thank you to Las
Vegas now Las Vegas real estate now for
sponsoring the saving call
702-203-1165 or just visit
lvrealestatyradio.com